check out Tom Hiddleston hanging with Ed
Sheeran at a secret Sirius XM show in
New York on Monday it's a little weird
considering Ed is one of Taylor Swift's
best pals and Tom is her ex and on
Tuesday Tom dodged questions about
Taylor on The Today Show your
relationship with Taylor Swift I make
clear distinction between my work which
I absolutely dedicate myself to which is
for the public and my private life is
private men get me in trouble
and yet this IDI covers the new issue of
Rolling Stone and admits he's hooked up
with some of Taylor's famous mates while
on tour with a superstar quote it was
very easy I would often find myself in
situations just kind of waking up and
looking over and being like how the [ __ ]
did this happen I'm likely not shocking
people as for those rumors that Ann
Taylor are releasing another duet soon
here's what he told et this week no this
year it's it's something something looks
like an ongoing conversation it will
definitely happen again but it I don't
know when that's gonna be
you